[Music]
I reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm
John
we're gonna watch today a patron video
request and a barber war tears whatever
video you request we must definitely do
ten times out of ten is a reaction
request every once in a while God
decides to bend the rules a little bit
and someone will request a video that is
not a reaction but today it's another
freaking reaction that's for Andrew
Hayes who only requests WatchMojo videos
like lists I usually make for good
discussions Andrew Hayes awesome movie
review channel seriously go check it out
and Andrew I heard you're gonna be down
here in September you know what that
means you're gonna be knocking at our
front door hey let me in and I'm gonna
be like sorry don't know who you are get
away from me you fifteen year old boy
and then I'm gonna tase you and we're
gonna call the police
haha just kidding we're totally gonna do
drugs on my birthday let's took a turn
is that who we think it is welcome to
watchmojo.com or we begin we publish new
videos every day so be sure to subscribe
for more great content yeah we'll be
looking at it happy fourth you were
famous rules for Easter Egg typecasting
don't beat each other Carrie I'm gonna
wait for me you know there's Gordon
America number 10 mystic pizza Matt
Damon this attendance coming-of-age
flick is best remembered for its rom-com
center as three waitresses of a small
pizza joint including a young Julia
Roberts navigate their romantic lives
but while following the ups and downs of
Daisy Jojo and cats laws it might be
easy to overlook then newcomer but
current a Lister Matt Damon in his debut
role Matt Damon plays Steamer younger
brother Joe he's a Floyd boyfriend a
small role he only appears in the one
dinner scene in which little steams
dismember you tamale provides a little
scream levity in an otherwise tense
family affair it's the shit's team
number nine carry John Travolta Brian De
Palma successfully made Stephen King's
debut novel a classic horror experience
in the role of Carey versus possible
Russ maybe when we get to the torture
totally is one of the most iconic scenes
in the history of the horror genre
newcomers to the film however or
sometimes I find a very familiar face
before John Travolta Don Danny Zuko is
leather jacket he played Billy Nolan a
looser older boyfriend of Chris
Hargensen and one of the bullies
responsible for Kerry's terrible prom
number eight planes trains and
automobiles Kevin Bacon in this best
news comment two men are forced together
with increasingly awkward odds as they
attempt to actually don't remember that
in transportation or another with the
combined comedic antics of Steve Martin
and John Candy
it's easy to forget anyone else in the
film at all and one scene however we get
a ghostly young Kevin Bacon who despite
only being credited as taxi racer and
working with little screen time manages
to make an impression nonetheless with
the Winnie grin and devilish sideways
glances he raised Martin's character
Neil page for what felt like the last
bacon taxi in New York City
[Music]
number seven spider-man 3 oh yeah that's
active really I made a meme about that
it's really just easy whatever get
through high school and unfortunate
cause it looks so different now yeah in
burkas case the bully was Flash Thompson
who fans will remember from the comics
as Peters classic tormentor we first saw
Joe Manganiello and the role back in the
2002 beginning of the trilogy
ridiculously how matched when he picks a
fight with Parker I'll never 71 this
Jerry Bruckheimer produced outing is
more than just this 40 like God along
with his black roommates right away and
he struggles in Alexandria Virginia to
allow black students to play on the TC
Williams high school football team
seriously barely in this Alan Bosley
aisle player put in during an important
play in a critical if ribbed match is in
fact a fresh-faced Ryan Gosling I could
play with Roosevelt but I cannot play
with these Devils
well he doesn't get much screen time
even then the Canadian heartthrob had
undeniable magnetism and one of those
faces you just can't forget number five
Zoolander Alexander Skarsgard whoa
really really ridiculously good-looking
considering this freely - Wow David
Bowie Owen Wilson
Will Ferrell Mia yoga vich David
Duchovny and Vince Vaughn you'd be
forgiven for overlooking a bad name star
star plays Mekas one of their two
legends are roommates
it's like excuse me but have you ever
heard of styling gel sadly he's not
longer the fight ended to cheer up Derek
he perishes in a terrible fire
yeah yeah that's what that was okay
right it also brought siblings Jake and
making Gyllenhaal to public attention
even after multiple viewings though what
with all the metaphysical concepts and
time-travel talk you just might have
missed a young Seth Rogen
he plays Ricky Dan for a student who
bullies Gina Malone's character at the
bus stop acts out in class and attacks
dolly and Gretchen on Halloween night Oh
a sickly he's a jerk
it's an odd rule Stephen now well-known
funny man play but it when you're
starting out you take whatever roles
come your way that's 23 Sin City Nick
Offerman
what the shutters are heavy and to be
honest it took us a straight-talking
turnes Ron Swanson on the American
sitcom Parks and Rec
Nick Offerman had a small role in - Wow
when your character is a hit man sent to
take out Bruce Willis's character in
this case detective John Hartigan you
know it can only end one way for you
badly a man of few words he is not long
for the screen here but next time you
watch it you'll be unmissable - Saving
Private Ryan Nathan Fillion yeah this
hybrid also brought together a stellar
cast of future All Stars including Paul
Giamatti
Bryan Cranston and Vin Diesel so this
was a tough call but the vote here had
to go to fan favorite character actor
Nathan doh surprise pourings owner at
ease while the Alberta born actor seems
to have a role either by her voice and
nearly everything today and is perhaps
best known or at least adored for his
role of Malcolm Reynolds captain of the
serenity and the short-lived hit Firefly
back in 1999 he was private James
Frederick just a big fella
fortunately for his private he was just
that characters okay before we unveil
our number one pick here are a few
honorable mentions my dad's name Mitch
and he's he's a submarine commander what
about Elijah Wood and
yeah the future - he works for WBAL on
radio yeah she's great looking great
little tad on the unconscious side sort
of - yeah I forgot my monitor come buddy
so what are you 12
Michelle Williams whoa I'm gonna meet
you in Los Angeles
number one Apocalypse Now Harrison
that's right oh why me it non-classic
has a little of everything and now you
know it has Harrison four to two years
off to set up a new home the newcomer
Harrison Ford had yet to truly make the
a-list and with the dunes how skull
bruises Martin Sheen and Marlon Brando
this was an impact you didn't never ever
Lucas yes it's better not to George
Lucas he is one of the military officers
who briefs jeans Captain Benjamin L
Willard award is to assassinate the road
Colonel Kurtz when you find the colonel
infiltrate his teams like you said it
would it would be there yeah I feel like
cool dumpy maybe one scene you'll wonder
how you ever missed them you understand
captain
greenies mission Edo does not exist
nor will it ever exist do you agree with
our picks I know like 40 videos per se
we have a couple of those you could just
have forgotten that they were in yeah
they're not necessarily shocking to be
reminded about I feel like this list
would have worked better as 10 famous
actors you forgot or it yeah yeah I
think that would have worked a lot
better the most shocking one to me it
was Nick Offerman in Sin City yeah I
completely missed that yeah I didn't
forget I've seen Nick Offerman several
times and I remember this scene yeah
even when I'm like that is Nick Offerman
yeah when they showed the wide shot I
was like what where was it or Joe
Manganiello and spider-man I feel like
is another one yeah me too miss like
that's one I know but that's because
I've looked them up or something
I learned that a long time ago but that
is something that I'll even sometimes
forget like it doesn't immediately come
to mind but if you were to ask me who
plays Flash Thompson that I'd pick my
brain to go oh yeah Joe Mannino yeah
yeah that's what next thing he can
definitely miss because he looks so
different I mean he's still like a good
looking young dude but now he's like
sexy insanely buff like what the hell
speaking of dude who the completely
transformed his look and appearance
Alexander Skarsgard on True Blood as
well yeah Sewell and there's a family
favorite so I've seen that movie like a
million times and that was a shock there
especially yet cuz he's not buff in this
movie like he does look nerdy yeah you
know and he's such a goof in both of
those scenes that yeah I completely that
was a shock to me it's easy to see those
guys when they become famous and go oh
that's why they our they haven't look at
their looks and their body type and yeah
and then you look at how they start oh
man did you just start off like insanely
cut today this new they've had to adapt
in their careers over time have a day I
feel like most of them you will just
kind of forget a lot of them are more
like oh yeah that's right they're in it
yeah Harry's one of those were okay yeah
I just remember Carrie and I'm not
shocked that John Travolta's in it at
all cuz I didn't miss that
if you were to see Kerry and you see
John Travolta you're not gonna take a
glance and go wait a minute wait a
minute is that Judge revolta well I'm
Kerry's also like a classic so it's not
as hard to believe that he would be in
there yeah but that's close to the top
of the list so I'm a little more
forgiving with that Matt Damon and
mystic pizza
I knew that forever and I was like the
only thing I ever actually knew your boy
my boy reiji sling g-string Ryan
g-string that's your stripper name yeah
[Laughter]
dance tonight man that'd be perfect is
the future in your career want Ryan
Gosling to do that for me hey your
g-string is buff now you know he is he's
not like a stick anymore like he is here
you can't be average in Hollywood in
these days you gotta be hey you gotta
eat five chickens a day and this meant
it was your time with the Jews only way
keep up the rest of the world now it's
weird in with that movie because even
when I wasn't in my I loved Ryan Gosling
phase
I always remember he was in this film
for some reason his look does stand out
I can never remember exactly what his
lines were or what like the important
role he played in the but his look did
stand out so what they say here you know
you just can't for you in his face for
some reason it's a good point which also
makes me go oh I see on this list it's
impossible to miss seeing him that first
time in this movie I feel like for him
they could have gone goose bumps cuz
that that's all has blown my mind like
more than a show yeah but this doesn't
say movie and just says rolls man yeah
Seth Rogen and Donnie Darko I completely
forgot yeah I feel like that's a piece
of trivia that I forget until I'm
reminded every few years that's a good
point though what they say about in the
beginning actors just do take on
whatever roles they can yeah I feel like
I said the river first became big people
didn't viewed the guy is like a hard
worker Natalie started like now he's
writing this movie now he's directing
this movie and I was producing prove it
yeah it really proved it but when you
look at the early stages of his career
this guy's
a hard worker forever when you see his
personality - he just seems like such a
laid-back cool relaxed guy who finds
everything silly so it's just kind of
interesting to me when I see this guy
back here in Donnie Darko days like man
this guy really has come a long way
though it's weirdly the thing that could
popped in my mind when I saw him here
well that's a role to wear I feel like
it is kind of easy to miss or forget
that he was in that movie cuz it's just
not the kind of role you're used to him
playing it's not the kind of personality
yeah yeah even if you're more familiar
with like freaks and geeks when he's
more of that age yeah type of character
I'm actually just not a big Daddy Darko
fan to begin with I respect that movie
but I don't have the urge to lay one
yeah Nathan Fillion had like the only
funny scene in the movie yeah the one
moment of levity I thinks his brother
did like seeing this particular scene
out of context made it that much more
like have like your world rocked and
then these guys are about to drop you
I feel like Nathan Fillion and Bruce
Campbell are kind of on a similar
wavelength in terms of their careers
they're both like huge and kind of this
like cults world and you know this like
really accessible cult and they're both
charming sarcastic I don't know if
they've ever paired up but I think
they'd be great to pair up in a movie
together I feel like it's probably
happened some houses small way but yeah
they could actually just like do a joint
venture I think that would be a lot of
fun yeah that would be a cult dream for
a lot of people yeah definitely I feel
like Elijah Wood and Back to the Future
2 would have been perfect for this list
mm-hmm cuz that's one you could
definitely miss yeah I'm trying to think
back to where he was right now he was in
there when you shoot a kid with a game
yeah the gun you have to use your hands
yeah a baby so yeah but hair is
important Apocalypse Now it's not
something I think you would miss though
that's just something you might kind of
forget because it's at the beginning of
the movie but he's the one who
introduces the plot and the mission so
he's an integral character to the story
I feel like that's an actor you'd have
missed if you watched Apocalypse Now
when it had just come out in the
theaters
maybe you forgot but like if you grew up
anytime after that movies been out I
feel like he's just another actor in
that yeah definitely definitely I feel
like him in American Graffiti is easier
to miss than that there probably is
American Graffiti as a cowboy had he's
doing an accent yeah he just looks like
Professor Indiana Jones yeah this is
what Andy did when he got called in the
war I mean this came out in June so I
don't know when they like recorded and
put this video together but even Matt
Damon and Alan Tudyk in Deadpool - oh
yeah no something like that or even Sam
Neill and thor ragnarok yeah I saw that
movie again just recently and I still
had to really squint through his beard
and hair to figure out those things I
think would have been better for this
list but you know there's a solid 40
percent here yeah that's right stepping
up mojo all right guys well do you agree
with watch Mojo's list what other roles
are there put your comments down below
on watch mojo's video you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check out
andrew Hayes's youtube channel people I
love Andrew Frederick Hayes